Almost heaven, older Twitch chat, all these emotes, wondering how to spell that.
Now we're older, everyone's moved on, but I remember Twitch chat from those days that are gone.
Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel you're not alone.
Kappa PogChamp, keep a forehead, BibleThumb, Twitch emotes.
I remember typing Dan's game, forehead, SwiftRage, PJ Salt and Failfish.
Life was easy, spamming all the time.
Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel you're not alone.
Kappa PogChamp, keep a forehead, BibleThumb, Twitch emotes.
Lookin' at a chat, I get a...
Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel you're not alone.
Kappa PogChamp, keep a forehead, BibleThumb, Twitch emotes.
How to use better twitch tv
How to hack snapchat accounts in 2021